[Music]
peralta are you eating an italian sub
for breakfast
i am but amy said i should eat more
veggies so i got extra pepperoni
smort excuse me
you need to watch yourself i'm sorry cop
all right let's everybody just stay calm
here oh what
are you going to arrest me for dancing
you call that
dancing this is dancing
what is happening i'm diffusing the
situation
[Music]
[Applause]
dancing captain let's capture my life
oh why is my phone always dead i paid 13
for it
don't worry oh my hands are covered in
butter from making butter
i'm on it must record
camera on all right here we go dancing
over
situation diffused
huh it's funny when people call dentist
doctor we are doctors
we do four years of medical school now
it's called dental school but we learn
about the entire body
but if you had cancer you can call a
dentist you know it's actually harder to
get into dental school than medical
school well because there are fewer
dental schools
because most people want to become
actual doctors that's ridiculous
it's not like we're college professors
calling ourselves doctors that's the
same thing my friend
sure it is when someone has a heart
attack on a plane do they yell out yo
does anybody here have an art history
phd a phd
is a doctorette it's literally
describing a doctor maybe let's refocus
no the problem here is that medical
practitioners have
co-opted the word doctor okay captain i
know we live in a world where anything
can mean anything
and nobody even cares about animal
apparently that's a trigger for me yeah
apparently
i tried to suck it up and go back to
work i put on my uniform and got in my
car next thing i knew i was
on a plane to mexico didn't even pack a
bag i bought a bundle of novelty shirts
at a nearby gift shop this one says
what's up beaches
instead of [ __ ] for human reasons but
you hate humor well i'm a joke now so
it suits me guys i have a great idea for
a prank before hold comes in i'm gonna
put ink on the podium where he puts his
hands
i don't think he'll fall for that i did
how i haven't even opened this yet i
guess it's unrelated captain holt hates
pranks this is gonna backfire man ugh
fine i'll tone it down i'll
move his podium a foot to the left what
he'll be so angry okay five inches
five three three one one all right i'll
move it a half inch
fine it's your funeral oh my god
worst prank ever so stupid holt's not
even gonna notice
good morning
you guys at the podium
[Laughter]
you're crazy how did you pull this off i
want you guys to think of me as one of
the boys so tonight i'll be swapping out
my captain's hat
for my kangol hat
call me raymond okay raymond in the
kangel hat i will definitely call you
raymond raymond and the kangal hat
it's the best night of my life i think
instead of us rising to your level
it's maybe time for you to stoop down to
ours
and that's just the start
what is this glutinous monstrosity
before me
the sugar in this is quite sweet
that's your whole impression i can hear
him doing that looks like
a sticky pillow i don't care for it
classical music
what's going on here what are you doing
captain hey nothing just
eating some marshmallows care for one
marshmallow
i knew it wait for it wait for it
901 amy santiago was officially late for
the first time ever
all right let's do this who's got
theories uh alarm didn't go up
all three alarms all with battery backup
come on who wants to take this seriously
ooh she was taken in her sleep that's
what i'm talking about
super dark boyle but way more plausible
than the sarge's idiotic alarm clock
theory
i bet she tucked herself into bed too
tight and got stuck maybe she fell into
another dimension where she's
interesting
it's 9 a.m why is no one working amy
santiago is a few minutes late and we're
all trying to guess why
i like to play i'd say she's
in line at the bank
this is fun it is fun but you're all
wrong
she clearly slipped through a subway
grade and is having terrible sex with a
mole man
there she is amy where have you been
we've been worried sick do you care to
explain yourself
i'm just 70 seconds late it's not a big
deal don't worry about it santiago you
will tell us and you will
tell us now there's a problem at the
bank hot damn
woo yes whoop whoop raymond in the
kangel
let's go
what's all this it's an after work hang
just trying to
turn up as it were we got uh snacks
games decorations chairs yes chairs
cool maybe we can mill around and small
talk about how some of us are big lying
liars who lie all the time like a bunch
of liars rosa i don't think that's
good party combo uh maybe we should just
name our favorite sailing knot
i'll start the bow line
how about some tunes cool
merry-go-round music yeah john philip
sousa the skrillex of his day
come on people hit the dance floor have
a good time
why is no one having a good time i
specifically requested it
we've been at this bachelor party for
over an hour wandering around aimlessly
and we haven't done
one bachelor party thing well terri if
you'd like i could share a lewd story
kevin got me quite horny this morning oh
see where did gina come from
and here comes jake
welcome to the big show
i was gonna sneak the plaque out without
anybody knowing but then i thought
so much more fun to make you watch now
enjoy
as i steal the plaque of destiny
ah trying to pick the lock el capitan
that'll take at least three minutes
by which time i will have hidden this
plaque somewhere you will never find
it
[Music]
voila of course you could break the
window
but you would never knowingly destroy
government property would you
well misread that one gina skate skate
like the witch
i call the game real ray or fake ray
and joining us is a very special
contestant captain ray holt himself
all right here's how the game works i
will say a phrase you tell me
if i made it up or if it's something
that captain holt
actually said in real life to an actual
human being i understand the logic of
this game great
phrase number one the futility of
lighting candles only to blow them out
immediately
is just one reason i find children's
birthday parties impractical
that's all fake i say fake tooth i don't
remember saying it so it must be fake
it was real carries kids
at their birthday party oh i remember
now okay do another one
all right phrase number two any smile
that lasts longer than a second and a
half is a con man's ruse that's fake
i think that's great i said it and i
meant it
that meat was good you know what we
should order more
meat yeah we should we're the steak
stuff
the steaks no no no wait charles already
gave us a name
and that is the only one we're gonna use
stay stuck stay
stunned stay stand stay start
it's charles oh no no what do we do what
do we do everyone calm down
it'll be fine i have an idea
why is everyone looking at me you just
said you had an idea and then you
stopped talking oh my goodness i'm very
intoxicated
while you were out being tardy i was
hard at work devising a special
punishment
i've crafted an intricate personal
high-five with everyone in this office
except you what but you hate high-fives
yes every minute of it was
hell but it'll be worse for you squad
dismissed
good-bye diaz salute into a fanny wagon
goodbye boyle
the snake charmer goodbye jeffers
that's the butt bump goodbye santiago
double fist bump reverse explosion into
a pete townsend strum
all right that was terrible but it's
over now and i made it through goodbye
leonard from xerox what
no no the copy guy now charles has to
think we're totally sober and we solved
his puzzle so we good yep i'm drunk as
hell that's not what i ask don't worry
about me
i've seen you do enough of these hair
brain schemes that ought to play along
if charles asks
what's wrong i'll just put on a koi
smile and say
nothing i was just checking to see if
there's anything we can do to help
and i hate to say it but i think there
is oh you think he's gonna get me drugs
from evidence
uh no something way weirder is happening
hit it jefferson
[Music]
distracted
you